day in the life of a rookie at nba
summer league this is jabari smith jr at
the houston rockets and this is my day
in life at summer league started my day
off with breakfast in a team room i
always have to go an omelette signed up
for an early missile with stacy she's
been the team for 20 years and she's the
goat
no game today so took the day to explore
vegas first off topgolf not my best
sport for that middle
swing needs some work but cool to
interact with the fans while i was there
christy chicken sandwich i don't like
pickles
it's my first time in vegas so i had to
check out the hype around the iconic
sign
good to see you and headed off to meet
taylor rooks to chat with her on her
show what's up y'all i'm in the studio
with taylor rooks y'all stay tuned we
talked for almost an hour y'all can
check it out on bleacher report
and headed to the arena to catch some
summer league action before calling
tonight just got back to the hotel and
that's a wrap appreciate it thanks for
joining my day in the life